yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
my way from Norway and while I ever
really tell what's going on the sky what
back I have this check have this scoring
function activated and he's just far far
ahead and in our match Knight to f5
Knight to f5 others t6 him ok but ya
know this this gets funky and we had
this before he's playing this bed line
again check but it's it's one of those
bad lines that still a tricky y term is
falling far behind in development
but um gets this temporary extra porn g3
Queenie for is very embarrassing so on
that some some other movie needs to play
okay this one and J 95 is probably good
there should be 2 95 and I feels like a
digital via deja vu I had all this
against him before completely winning
and somehow blundering this game away it
really happened something very similar
we had before okay after Queen g 3 i'm
going to take a plane IG form to f2
maybe I had I had something better even
but I don't want to spend your age sem
okay justice check young and I just
going to see to jack okay I can play
rook you want him
yeah come on let's do that
oh they're not sums completely sick
[ __ ] Bishop h6 tricks at some point
hmm
what about d5 if he takes rookie two
chickens probably not not really working
hmm
this blade che college 6m
hmm
I cannot calculate this position Terrell
completely completely bonkers just
playing the most active moves that I can
think of
check
stock cannot move the night if I was
thinking oak the aid just I just
activating just activating and I'm not
sure I'm really threatening something my
poor darling you
maybe something like Bishop t6 and
taking on g3
G for Bishop g3 even traps this but he
can play Bishop g5 not very sick
you
and he can play Bishop to d2 Wow not
quite sure where I'm going after that to
a to chat to g1 la time walking into a
self in mm-hmm why could still take on
g3 but this is also a self in
what the position do you feel I can take
here hope I need to get rid of this is
bloody bishop maybe I may be 95 m yes 95
so that i can add the ante kanji too
terribly complicated position check Wow
jump I have no idea what's going on here
no idea at all and he's playing
instantly of course in 93 or something
ok
check
time warning check check check check
check check check check black what his
hometown very close very close to
getting the last boy what mad I'm really
are a bit sick of that this kind of I
had had the same crap position against
him before and I've as student managed I
didn't manage back then to win as well
and he still went for this nonsense
again god it's so so strange this
position yeah maybe h5m still age five
yeah probably in the probably age five
but rookie one looks really tempting
check yeah what does completely
completely crazy yeah 95 i have what my
problem is i completely overlooked this
check i thought he and you can take here
now I he needs to take and give away one
of the bishops but he's kinda strong
youth which I didn't see and now I this
is you can you can also just play
roulette here so completely completely
crazy stuff probably we we both had
their chances check ya can't completely
irritated me with the stone of check see
all right yeah now I get a good fight
next time I need to I need to really
play age five that is exactly the same
position i'm pretty sure and he repeated
this this crab open again it's pretty
clear that this is Jack just terrible
for wide maybe I even have some some
better move here and then then taking I
mean it's a just just just bad for what
I from four pieces in play yeah but it
doesn't seem to be a direct winner can't
computer wants to do that regaining the
porn yeah it's not bad at all but I'm
still complicated to play yeah
yeah next time I'll get you thanks for
watching